Our Connections – Ō Tātou Hononga
Good access, infrastructure and transport helps to ensure
there is a high quality of
life in the Waimakariri District.
With 11,000 residents travelling to Christchurch
for work each day, our inter-district connections
are critical to meeting the expectations of
commuters.
Increased use of public transport and alternative
commuting options will be required to avoid
increasing congestion.
We also need to ensure our towns are well
connected by roads, cycleways and public transport
to cater for our growing population and that
infrastructure keeps up with growth.
We also need to think about emerging transport
technologies such as autonomous and electric
vehicles and the potential increased digital
connectivity has to replace commuting.
Our District - Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz